thank you guys for coming by the way to
the 25th anniversary of the Academy Film
Archive with a very unique opportunity
to view a Hollywood classic just as
audiences would have experienced in 1952
singing the rain didn't start with the
story it started with a song well I
actually had several songs in fact
screenwriters Betty Comden and Adolphe
green the writing team behind on the
town were given the task of weaving
together MGM producer Arthur freed and
Maceo her brown songs into an entirely
new musical most of the film's songs
were originally written in the 1920s
most notably the title song singing in
the rain which was originally written
for the Hollywood revue of 1929 that's
pretty cool
fitting together a mixture of songs from
the freed catalogue into a seamless
story was no easy task
writer Adolphe Green said there was
nothing more difficult even comparing to
the job to higher mathematics however
once calm Didem and green settled on a
central idea Hollywood's transition to
sound the script began to fall into
place the film has numerous references
to the late silent and early sound era
of Hollywood with many of the film's
characters being modeled after real
people the character of gossip columnist
Dora Bailey seen in the film's opening
sequence of the Grauman's Chinese
Theatre was loosely modeled after
Hollywood gossip columnist
Louella Parsons is a real person the
character of director Roscoe Dexter was
modeled after Busby Berkeley and
apparently the character of studio head
Aref Simms Simpson is said to be modeled
after producer Arthur freed himself Don
Lockwood slappable dialogue in the
disastrous preview of all the all
talking the duelling Cavalier was
loosely based on the one-on-one of John
Gilbert sounds films redemption in 1930
but what truly helped to breathe new
life into the film songs was gene
Kelly's innovative choreography and I
just have to say speak to that he wildly
inspired me one thing about gene Kelly's
choreography that I always look at and
go back to was his use of his
surroundings and use of props and for me
I just that was so exciting I was like
wow you can use like a lamppost
you know I were being
ten years old in New York City and I'm
sure we could always all relate but we'd
find a lamppost and we all hang off of
it and what we're all like Oh sing in
the rain you know it's uh it's iconic
and it said did that Duffy tree to my
heart genes choreography for singing in
the rain
not only showcases his versatility as a
dancer but also skillfully emphasizes
the strengths of jeans co-stars Donald
O'Connor's background in vaudeville
enabled him to bring in immeasurable
athleticism to the part of Cosmo Brown
by the way if you look at that scene you
took a big break break dancing and
b-boys you know now do all this kind of
stuff you know if you see him he's doing
some crazy stuff and it's like that's
correct where was born I feel like in
the man was people his nose up about
Donnell Connor the old I caught him okay
in the make him laugh scene Donald
Donald runs up a wall and completes a
somersault
a move that was one on one that Donald
at Donnell had performed many times on
stage to give him self-confidence for
the sequence Donald brought his brother
over to help him he actually rehearsed
with a rope he tied it on a rope and
practiced with him so that's kind of
cool too I find this very interesting
in contrast 19 year old Debbie written
nineteen years old Wow 19 years old 19
year old Debbie Reynolds was not a
trained dancer I know that feeling it's
raining a non-answer
despite the grueling rehearsal and
shooting schedule Kelly found Debbie to
be a great copyist and strong as an ox
while Debbie called gene the most
exciting director I've ever worked with
I want to work with him but perhaps the
most iconic of all the film's dance
sequence is the film's main number
featuring Kelly an umbrella and an
artificial downpour Kelly's
collaboration with freed Donnan and
Comden and green and the many other
artists turned singing the rain into a
warm and nostalgic look into one of
Hollywood's most important periods of
transition which would change the face
or rather the voice of pictures for all
time